i want to go through and talk a little
bit about what fidel castro actually did
because the left will never tell you
straight
exactly what was wrong with fidel castro
because the thing about fidel castro for
the left
is the left is pretty much fine the left
is pretty much okay
with anything that they'll that other
leftists do
they they're not in love with the mass
murder but if mass murder has to get
done in order to create the new utopia
they can live with it so the front page
of the new york times said a
revolutionary who defied the us
and held cuba in his thrall well he
didn't actually hold cuba in his thrall
he actually
created a giant gulag and sentenced
everybody in the country to stay in it
and he wasn't a revolutionary so much as
he was a socialist dictator who murdered
all dissidents
but i think that it's important to go
through some of the facts about about
fidel castro so we will do that today
so first of all fidel castro took over
the country in 1959 he took over from a
guy named general batista general
bautista was also a dictator but he was
sort of a right wing dictator
and general batista under bautista cuba
was one of the richest countries in
latin america
it was on the upswing it was sort of
like not a good guy bautista but
sort of like pinochet except less
violent he was
eventually going to end up transitioning
into a form of democracy in all
likelihood instead
there's a violent revolution with castro
at its source and here is fidel castro
taking power here's what it looked like
outside havana's presidential palace
hundreds of thousands rally at the call
of revolutionary leader fidel castro
who estimated their number at a million
most of the throng wears the colors of
castro's 26th of july movement
they are in an exultant mood as the man
who overthrew the batista dictatorship
calls on them
to approve the public trials and
executions of pro-batista figures
guilty of war crimes and atrocities the
executions
some 250 to date have been widely
criticized by many as too hasty and
summary
even if justified says castro the cuban
revolutionary government has no reason
to offer explanations to america or to
anyone
except the people of cuba
castro asks his audience if it favors
the summary court martial
it gets his answer in a roar of approval
all in all he ends up executing
thousands and thousands of people
uh he conspired with the mass murderer
shea guevara we'll talk about shea in
just a minute to overthrow
falgencia batista who was that dictator
and then he began a gorilla campaign
resulting in his takeover
of the island he immediately exiled
priests he exiled
all all religious figures he destroyed
religious schools he nationalized all
businesses
he imprisoned in murders and murdered
his enemies within the first
three months he had between six hundred
and eleven hundred people
shot shea guevara said there's a direct
quote from shea this this
piece of crap who you see people walking
around with his face on t-shirts it's
like walking around
again with a stalin t-shirt so to send
men to the firing squad judicial proof
is unnecessary
is what che guevara said these
procedures are an archaic bourgeois
detail this is a revolution
and a revolutionary must become a cold
killing machine
motivated by pure hate we must create a
pedagogy of the paradigm that's the
the execution wall so you have to teach
people through the execution while
castro actually imprisoned more of his
citizens by percentage than hitler or
stalin
by 1961 he had imprisoned 300 000 human
beings
he asked the soviet union to actually
nuke the united states in 1961 during
the cuban missile crisis
castro supported terrorist groups all
over the world ranging from farc in
colombia to shining path in peru and the
santianistas in nicaragua
hundreds of thousands of cubans fled
millions actually
many drowned in the ocean thousands of
people drowned in the ocean as they
attempted to sail to florida
between 1959 and 1992 at least two
million cubans
fled cuba now some of the lies that
you'll be told is that he didn't
impoverish cuba he absolutely did
the average gdp per capita in in cuba
uh when castro took over was a little
bit over two thousand dollars per person
per year
by 1999 the average gdp per capita
remember there's a 40-year period by
1999 the per capita gdp in the nation
was 2 300 so it advanced 300
in 40 years according to discover the
networks the average daily wage for
agriculture workers
in cuba in 1958 was three bucks the
average daily wage in france at the time
was 2.73 cuba had in 1958 the year
before
castro took over the highest standard of
living of any latin american country and
half of europe
here's the wall street journal the cuba
that castro inherited
was developing but relatively prosperous
and ranked third in latin america in
doctors and dentists and daily calorie
consumption
per capita its infant mortality rate was
the lowest in the region
and the 13th lowest in the world cubans
were among the most literate latins
and had a vibrant civic life with
private professional commercial
religious and charitable organizations
castro destroyed all of it he ruined
agriculture by imposing collective farms
making cuba dependent first on the
soviets and later on oil from hugo
chavez's venezuela
in the past half century cuba's export
growth has been less than hades
and now even doctors are scarce because
so many are sent abroad to earn foreign
currency
hospitals don't even have sheets or
aspirin the average monthly income is
twenty dollars
government food rations are inadequate
as for that health care you always hear
about the cuban health care
absolute crap there are three systems
they're the socialist revolutionaries
you got good care
they're the foreigners who come and pay
with cash like fat michael moore and
then there is and then there is
the actual people of cuba this is
according to jay nordlinger of national
review he said hospitals and clinics are
crumbling
conditions are so unsanitary patients
may be better off at home
whatever home is if they do have to go
to the hospital they must bring their
own bed sheets
soap towels food light bulbs even toilet
paper
that's how poor health care is imagine
you go to the hospital and you have to
bring your own light bulbs and toilet
paper
basic medications are scarce doctors
have been known to reuse latex gloves
okay the whole point of latex gloves
that you don't reuse them as for the
infant mortality rate they're constantly
bragging about the infant mortality rate
that's because they do all sorts of
prenatal checkups so they want to keep
that statistic artificially high
and the way that they do that is they do
prenatal checkups if there's any danger
to the pregnancy at all they simply
abort the kid
so the abortion rates in cuba are
extraordinarily extraordinarily high
it really is a horrifying system of
government and that's been brought about
by by the castro but look how the media
just
worshipped the castro so this is ed
sullivan ed sullivan
uh had on castro uh this is 1961 i
believe
uh or 1959 and here's ed sullivan who's
then the most popular television host in
the united states praising
fidel castro in school i understand you
were a very fine student a very fine
athlete
were you a baseball teacher yes a world
teacher
basketball basketball
football and every every everything
every sport
well undoubtedly all of that exercise
you did in school
prepared you for this role man yes it
helped me very much
now in this world this is a fine young
man
and a very smart young man with the help
of god in our prayers and with the help
of the american government
he will come up with the sort of
democracy down there that america should
have
he'll create the sort of democracy
america should have unbelievable this is
how the media treated fidel castro a
mass murdering dictator
mass murdering dictator castro on face
the nation here is here's castro
appearing on face the nation this is
from 1959.
because public opinion in cuba is now
very strong
and with a tremendous force
nobody is enough powerful
to opposite now the public opinion of
the free
country of cuba okay so he says that
public opinion will drive and this is
always what socialist revolutionaries
would be dictators say whenever somebody
talks about public opinion making might
right
that's never a good thing it's why
demagogues are scary right people who
come up and they say well the public
says i can do this
it doesn't matter what the law says it
doesn't matter what the constitution
says the people want it we'll have
summary executions
again tens of thousands of people
murdered hundreds of thousands of people
imprisoned
by fidel castro okay here's shay guevara
at the united nations
talking about human rights it says as
fidel castro has said
so long as the concept exists as the
prerogative of the nations of
independent peoples
that's the right to all peoples will not
accept the exclusion
of our people from that right
three years later he was dead and he was
dead because uh he went
into other parts of latin america and
attempted to lead coups there
communist coups theirs he's talking
there about how nobody should interfere
with cuba
and then he promptly went to latin
america and attempted to start a
revolution of bolivia
and was killed for his trouble thank god
he was a really terrible human being
che guevara you want to see what it was
like for cubans living in castro's cuba
people still are by the way thanks to
the incompetence of barack obama and
this idiotic policy imposed over the
last 50 years in the united states i've
never been in favor of this policy
that the united states has with regard
to uh with regard to non-assassination
uh it makes no sense to me i don't see
why literally millions upon millions
generations of people
should live in terror and suffering
because we have to let an old piece of
crap like
an old disgusting desiccated piece of
human debris
like fidel castro live we would have
been better off killing him um but
but here's here's what it was like in
cuba and still is liking cuba people
can't escape it's a giant prison
uh here is uh some footage of cuban
refugees here's what people were doing
just to get out of castro's cuba while
all of these westerners were praising
cuba as this halcyon of light and
liberty
here is here's what it actually looked
like for people trying to get out in
2003 news media the world over broadcast
this image a dozen cubans sailing for
freedom
aboard an old green chevy truck luis
and his three-year-old son angel were on
board
luis explained to me that few new cars
entered
cuba after the revolution in the 1950s
but his old one worked just fine
he tells me he was scared building the
boat in secret
and pushing from shore in the dark of
night
but he was willing to risk everything
for a better life in america
okay i mean this is again hundreds of
thousands of people
attempting to escape cuba in in the
early 1980s there were so many people
trying to escape the fidel castro
actually said fine
and then he sent a huge number of kind
of the the cuban
criminal class uh he let them escape he
let all the criminals
go to miami uh and that's why he saw a
major upsurge in crime and
the drug trade in miami in the early
part of the 1980s but people have been
attempting to float in cars
i mean this is how you ended up with
with the situation uh with um
the what was the uh gonzales what was
the name of the the kid who was deported
back to cuba
after his after his dad died on the way
over uh
from or his mother died on the way over
from cuba and then he was deported back
to cuba
thanks to the clinton administration
people have been attempting to get out
of cuba
for for 50 years thanks to the castros
here's some footage of castro's
prisoners speaking about what it was
like to be a dissident in castro's cuba
it was like being in the depths of hell
the suffering made me a little crazy
but my husband and children wrote to me
and that kept me going
she said were arrested at a small
anti-government demonstration in may
2014. their crime they say chanting down
with fidel castro
education for cubans has been about fear
and how to be afraid
about how to avoid confrontation with
the authorities because they have power
they teach you what they want you to
know but not really what goes on in the
world
he said both were released on january
8th according to their prison papers
the pair spent eight months behind bars
in what they say were appalling
conditions
okay and that's not unusual lots of
people died and just went missing uh in
in castro's prisons
castro had a special hatred for
homosexuals so very early in his regime
he basically rounds it up homosexuals
hear his testimony from
some gay folks who were rounded up by
fidel castro and put in prison camps
is
themselves
[Music]
some killed themselves okay that was not
uncommon in castro's cuba
uh and uh again this is somebody who
mass executions were not were not
uncommon in castro's cuba here is a
here is a footage of one of the original
executions this was released by the
castro regime very early on
this was supposedly a member of
batista's regime
so delightful folks delightful folks the
reason that i do all of this is because
the left in america and in the west
glorify people like castro they really
do
and it's truly disgusting